good morning everyone the the title of
our presentation today is emotions
matter I guess I should start off by
asking
our feeling but I'm going to hold off on
that just for a moment so why are we
here today I think we're here today
because we have a common belief or a
common vision first that too many kids
are being bullied you heard from David
the statistics that the stats are on 28%
of children are experiencing bullying on
a regular basis we also know the
consequences of bullying are are pretty
severe and I say that for all players
involved in bullying we often only think
about the targets of bullying but we
also need to think about the kids who
become bullies themselves also thinking
about the bystanders how many of you
have witnessed bullying in your lives
and how many of you felt extremely
uncomfortable by that experience and how
many of you felt like you don't know
exactly what to do about it yeah so we
need to teach skills obviously to to all
the players and the third point that I
want to make before I really begin is
that what we now know is that bullying
prevention programs are mostly
ineffective so the question is why we
spending billions of dollars a year in
our schools on approaches that don't
seem to make a difference what I hope
that you learn today from my
presentation is that if we take a whole
school approach or a whole district
approach to teaching social-emotional
learning that there's more hope that
there are better possibilities for
children and interestingly enough you
get more than just less bullying in
schools what you get is children with
greater well-being teachers will less
stress at burnout more positive school
climates that our academic performance
in the list goes on so by taking
seriously children's social-emotional
development and the adults involved in
their education great things can happen
let's just go back a little bit to
defining bullying so what we know is
that there is normal aggression in life
children will get angry children will be
mean children fight normal fighting is
quite healthy for a child development
when we think about bullying however we
go
into more detail we're talking about
intentional harm that's repeated and has
a power imbalance so by way of example
just about one about six months ago I'm
44 years old and I was one of those kids
who who was bullied for quite a while as
a middle schooler and luckily I got into
the martial arts things improved for me
my parents got me help but so I went
sort of bully-free for maybe 25 30 years
recently as an adult professional I was
at a meeting and there was someone who
is a little bigger than I am a little
bit stronger personality than I have and
the long story short was that I did a
presentation on bullying and I think
this person might have been threatened
by my presentation and at the end of my
presentation decided to show a video of
a kid being bullied by a coach and of
course I'm looking at this video
thinking like what is going on here this
is I don't get it like what is what are
you doing
and so I sit there it happens and at the
end of my present at the end of the
video he goes I just wanted to show that
because that's what Mark looked like
before he got his black belt so here it
was as a 44 minute I'll literally
regressed to being 13 little I was
sitting there felt powerless
it was clearly intentional and this
person has a reputation of being a bully
it was only one experience for me but
what a strong experience and how quickly
I regressed to being that 13 year old
kid who felt powerless who wasn't sure
what to do so we know is that bullying
has long-term effects on us it doesn't
just go away it affects our
psychological well-being for our lives
in recent statistics we know that a
significant numbers of children report
being bullied ever 28 percent say they
were bullying the last six months and
between 7 to 15 percent say they're
bullied chronicling chronic bullying it
presented these statistics I won't go
through them in a lot of detail but as
you can see it's pretty flat
that on average does lots of statistics
and it's a very complicated construct to
measure but on average what we're seeing
is around 25 to 30 percent of children
experiencing bullying so for me you know
I have the question is why don't these
programs work and when you look at
anti-bullying programs what we learn is
a few things the first is that most
really focus on the measuring or
assessing the frequency they look at
rules how do we create more rules how do
we monitor hotspots how do we enforce
consequences maybe they even Institute
zero-tolerance policies and many of them
even rely on bystanders and that's
becoming even for me a more interesting
approach this relying on bystanders when
I asked all of you earlier how many of
you have witnessed bullying many of you
raised your hand then I asked all of you
how many of you felt comfortable or
capable as a kid of helping out the
child who is being bullied and what we
now know is it's very complex it's not
such an easy phenomenon I'm a very
sensitive kid I was a sensitive kid I'm
hopefully a sensitive adult too and you
know for me to jump up and help a friend
who's being bullied when I feel smaller
more inferior would be very complicated
what I want to share with you today is
why we believe most bullying prevention
efforts are ineffective and the first is
that children are different
each of us has a personality and if you
are that more timid sensitive child it's
going to be really hard for you to stand
in and stand up for the bully I was a
victim I should say we also know is that
child development matters that our
children's social emotional and
cognitive development in terms of the
way we would help children manage
bullying the strategies that we use to
teach them how to help out so the third
is that all players need to learn skills
from our perspective bullying prevention
is not
just something for teaching or helping
children who have been targets of
bullying while we're not being
prevention focused why we're not
teaching children the skills they need
to navigate their social and emotional
lives how many of you who have witnessed
just for curiosity adult bullying raise
your hand so looking around the room
everyone keep your hands up nearly
everyone just a few months ago I did a
webinar for a large company here in
Connecticut and I asked about a thousand
people about their experiences and
bullying and 70 percent of the people on
that webinar said they witnessed
bullying on a regular basis in their
workplace this is adult bullying now
what we also know is that children learn
by watching don't they and what we also
have seen in our work is that many
children feel like they can bully others
in their school because they are
watching adults being mean and cruel to
other adults even in classrooms where
their assistant teachers we've seen
teachers bully the paraprofessional or
the assistant teacher and lo and behold
those children now bully other children
and those assistant teachers the final
thing I want to say is that school
climate and culture needs to be more
positive that until children feel as we
now know safe like they belong they feel
connected to their teachers to their
peers to their community likely the
Common Core Standards or any other
national education reform effort is not
going to have any impact you have to
want kids have to want to be there they
have to want to learn they have to have
that desire to be in school I think what
we're coming back to is what Aristotle
said millennia ago and it's interesting
as 2014 and finally this is in the first
symposium that I've been at in
Connecticut and I've been here 11 years
we were taking seriously the social and
emotional education of children so
Aristotle said it educating the mind
without educating the heart is no
education at all and maybe the time has
come you heard briefly about our new
center well where our Center is called
the Yale Center for emotional
intelligence
and the goal of our Center is to use the
power of emotional intelligence to
create a more healthy effective and
compassionate society so it's a broad
agenda we want to help children and
adults live healthier lives both
mentally physically we want to make sure
that people are effective in their
everyday lives at work in at home and at
school and finally how many of you
believe that it would be you know it
would be a good thing for children to be
kinder and adults to be more empathic
yeah good we're on the same page so we
have a mission in order to achieve our
vision and that mission is to
continuously conduct rigorous research
really unpack these experiences of
children and adults and also develop
innovative educational approaches for
schools and even other organizations for
people of all ages preschool to high
school to beyond to teach them the
skills they need to succeed so I did say
I was going to ask you how you're
feeling now I'm going to do it this is
one of our tools and we call it the mood
meter and the mood meter is an
evidence-based tool to help build
self-awareness to build emotion
vocabulary even the mood meter has two
axes the pleasant is access in the
energy axis I'm going to ask all of you
now to think about this pleasantness has
to do with what's going on for you here
it's your private subjective experience
it is your feeling of being welcome or
unwelcome pleasant unpleasant +5 would
mean that right now you're in the best
possible place in your life I mean you
could think of nothing else that you'd
rather be doing and sitting here
listening some guy talk about feelings
maybe somebody over there I hope so that
would be plus five some of you might be
like smack in the middle like sort of
like most people in Connecticut when you
ask them how they feel right how you
feeling hmm no real language no real
experience and some of you may be at
minus five maybe you're thinking my
goodness like this is a real waste of
time I could be you know
being productive right now so I'm going
to ask you right now to give yourself a
number on that x-axis how are you
feeling here next I'm going to ask you
to turn your attention to your body to
your physicality in terms of your
physiology how much energy are you have
do you have right now - five would mean
that you are in the deepest pool of
despair you've ever been in you are so
low energy that you are about to fall
asleep plus five you are just so
activated and energetic you can't
contain yourself for the looks of the
audience I have a lot of work ahead of
me
so what's your energy like right now low
moderate high and of course the axes
create four quadrants the yellow the
blue the red the gray so yellow plus it
was a lot of energy how many of you
there right now okay say about a quarter
of the row how about green you're
pleasant but low in energy okay some
more people anyone here not having such
a great day and the blue or the red so
no one is feeling unpleasant I'm like
this is like on video so we're like you
know we're going to talk about
authenticity in a little while the just
for curiosity if you were to do a little
like fly-on-the-wall and your teachers
lounge at your school right now or maybe
in some of the classrooms in your school
let you see a different distribution but
so all of you are fine but everybody
else is not doing so well yeah what I'd
like you to do right now is convert your
plot to a word what is the feeling word
that best describes how you were doing
right now take a moment
quick raise of hands just for curiosity
how many of you had some trouble finding
the best work raise your hand put your
hands up really high like stretch it out
look around the room please so we are
all adults and we as adults have
difficulty putting a word to our
feelings a name any hypotheses about why
that might be this is the
audience-participation part
yeah yes no it's not something that
comes up a lot and if it does what
happens if I say how you feeling what do
you normally say good fine leave me
alone any other thoughts about why we
might not be able to access a word yes
sir as adults as we mature we believe
that we should be making less excuses
for what we do in our lives and supposed
to be doers not feelers so it shouldn't
matter how I'm feeling as to whether or
not I can do my job or do what I'm
supposed to be doing right now or be a
parent or the you know co-worker your
driver it should be it should be an
independent and immaterial
so we don't think about it a lot because
it's not part of our daily equations and
just think and do you believe that know
if I'm going to ask about it
okay nice I'm gonna sort of wrap up this
little piece by asking you to think
about the strategy that's going to best
serve you this morning
so I'll be on for about five hours
talking about you know a lot of feelings
because since we don't do it we got to
spend a lot of time on it what is the
strategy that you will use to get the
most out of this presentation honestly
as you feel it's Friday right you might
say well what's the weekend what's your
strategy to remain open to maybe be a
little skeptical but stay open-minded
and absorb as much as possible just take
a moment and think about that strategy
who can share who has a strategy to
people see our Center really is going to
do great work for this state yes hooray
yes
breathe sit tall
eyes open and be relaxed okay thank you
who else yes my strategy think about the
children in my school this kind of help
and so I'm going to try to take back as
much as I can to terminate it amongst
the faculty and
how many of you have ever told the trial
at something like this I need you to pay
attention anyone all right
maybe you've even use like stick symbols
for it like if I needed you to pay
attention I would say like I need you to
pay attention right and it's like look
at me
anyone ever do that or maybe use this
hand signal and this sort of command
something like I need you to calm down
right be open focus what we've learned
from our research and our practice is
that those are those are complicated
ideas aren't they
how do you stay calm like what do you do
to stay calm how do you focus what do
you actually do in your brain to focus
and I hope that you get a little bit
more granular in terms of your
understanding of emotions today my hope
is by the way is that you'll be right
around there I wanted to share before I
move on yesterday or day before
yesterday I was in New York City working
with some schools and had one of the
most pleasant experiences of my career
was in a pre-k room and this little
adorable preschooler her name is Leila
and I was sitting in the carpet and the
teacher was doing a mood meter lesson
and the teacher said Leila's you want to
share where you're on the mood meter and
she got up and she a little kid like
this big and she pointed in the yellow
and then her teacher said you know why
are you in the yellow and she looked at
me like this little girl and she was
because the mood meter man is here and
it was
now I know my purpose in life so why do
we care about emotions we care about
emotions for five primary reasons we
care because we know from our research
and others research as well that
emotions affect our attention our memory
and our learning if your bread right now
you are elsewhere if you're feeling a
lot of anxiety about something going on
in your home life likely your brain is
using strategies that may not be
effective to help you deal with that and
you're not going to be as present as you
could be I can tell you myself as
someone who was that bullied kid and as
a teenager who was extremely anxious in
school because of fear of being hurt and
all kinds of challenges is I was not a
great student I couldn't focus my brain
was thinking how am I going to get home
without being hurt how am I going to get
to class B and who's going to be my
friend who's going to actually talk to
me who's not going to make fun of me
today and when your brain is being used
in that way it's not going to have as
many resources as it needs to be
available for the learning experience
it's just clear decision-making in
judgment just for curiosity has anyone
here ever made a bad decision yeah no
one wants to share that go back to your
freshman year in college maybe so we
won't do a pair of sugar pants today
the what we know from our research is
that emotions drive much of our
decision-making as a matter of fact
among educators we've studied recently
their emotion States drive the way they
grade their students so we think oh I'm
objective but lo and behold what we now
know is that certain mood states bias
the way you think about things
relationship quality for curiosity how
many of you sort of think about going
for coffee with the colleague at your
school or workplace who sort of is
bitter irritable
kind of disgruntled and angry all the
time how many of you think like well I
wonder if what they want to do for lunch
today or how many of you sort of steer
away from that person we don't tend to
like to be around people who display a
lot of negative affect who don't
demonstrate their ability to manage
their emotions effectively of course our
physical and mental health is affected
by our emotional skills
if we can't regulate our emotions how
can we manage those feelings of
nervousness or anxiety even excitement
and finally what we now know is that
people just perform better when they
have these skills both at home at school
and the workplace so what is this thing
called emotional intelligence I was very
fortunate in my career to have studied
with one of the founders of the theory
of emotional intelligence jack mayer and
then come to yell eleven years ago to
work with peter salome the two
originators of the theory of emotional
intelligence and they define back in
1990 this theory that emotional
intelligence is the ability to monitor
one's own and others feelings to
discriminate discriminate among them and
to use this information to guide one's
thinking in action so what they're
getting it here or what they were
getting at was that emotional
intelligence was this ability this
capacity a skill a competence but and it
had discrete components of it and what
we've done for the last 10 or so years
is really focused on what does what are
those discrete components the first is
recognizing emotion so I'm looking at
all of your facial expressions right now
monitoring your facial expressions and I
am a little worried you know it's just
I'm some of you I'm not sure what you're
feeling how many of you are somewhat
interested ok good yeah I was guessing
that I'm also monitoring my own
emotional experiences I'm checking my
physiology I am going with the thoughts
thinking about the pleasantness right
now the second is understanding emotions
where are emotions coming from why am i
angry why am i sad why am i fearful
why do I feel pride and importantly this
component of emotional intelligence has
to do with understanding how our
emotions influence our thinking our
judgment our decision-making and what we
know from that research that I did with
teachers recently was that their
emotions affected their decision-making
their judgment of this shouldn't work
but interestingly enough 90% at the end
of the study reported that he didn't
believe that that was the case so here
what we're showing is that emotions
influence how we think the decisions we
make but we may not be aware of it
the third is labeling emotions having
that vocabulary to describe the full
range and what research now shows is
that if you can name it you containment
how many have ever lived with or
nurtured a two-year-old who didn't have
a sophisticated vocabulary yet it's
challenging isn't it if you can't name
your feelings it's very hard to know
what to do with them expressing emotions
knowing that how and when to express
emotions this is a room filled with
people from a variety of cultures how
many of you work with students who are
from other cultures raise your hand
almost everyone how many of you notice
there are different rules associated
with emotions based on these cultures
yes they are so we need to be mindful of
that that the Korean child in the class
is looking down and is being different
is not being is not ignoring you or
dismissing you that it's based on his
cultural heritage the fifth is
regulating emotions what are those
strategies that we use to manage our
emotions effectively how many of you
just for curiosity believe that your
lives would be somewhat more healthy and
you'll be maybe even a little happier if
you were more skilled at regulating your
own emotions raise your hand okay some
of you many of you how many of you feel
like your lives will be better if
everybody who lived with and more
strategies
so that's a challenge right it's a very
American way we want everyone else to do
the work you see on the bottom here that
we assert that it's not just about the
skills but it's about attitudes and
knowledge a big part of our work is
convincing the world that emotions
matter that a child emotion skills will
make a difference in his life or her
life that teachers who are more aware of
the emotional displays if they are
having in their classrooms are going to
be more successful that leaders who are
more emotionally skilled will make a
difference so you have to have the
belief system that emotions matter
otherwise you just focus on other things
don't you then you have to develop
knowledge you have to learn about
emotions and it's a you could take get a
PhD in just one emotion so this is a big
field and then you have to develop the
skills of practicing and getting
feedback so that you become more adept
we've also focus on ways of measuring
emotional intelligence you can ask the
person I'm curious to know how
emotionally intelligent this audience is
so on a scale from one to five one you
are not very emotionally intelligent
five you are an emotional genius how
many of you give yourselves a one okay
no emotionally no emotional basket cases
here how about it too okay
very select group of people how about a
three ten percent how many of you give
yourselves a four raise your hands high
for is raise your hands so about 80% of
the row how many of you believe that 80%
of the room is above average the people
who raised their hand
so when we do these studies on pen and
paper with with students what we find is
that just the same thing 80% of the
students think they're more emotionally
intelligent than the other 80% anybody
studying math it doesn't work out very
well so self-report doesn't really work
I can ask everybody who you know how
emotionally intelligent they think you
are how many of you would like to rely
on your significant others report of
your emotional intelligence how many of
you like to rely on your students report
of your emotional intelligence so asking
others is tricky and the way we focus
the measurement of emotional
intelligence is using performance
assessment tools what do you actually
know and what can you do with your
emotion so we give people facial
expressions to decode we give them
scenarios that they have to
problem-solve about and when we do that
we find pretty interesting things part
of this right is self-knowledge is quite
limited how much feedback have you
gotten on your emotional intelligence in
life seriously how much formal training
have you received on the abilities of
recognizing understanding labeling
expressing regulating emotions for those
of you who went to become a teacher how
many of you are anybody in your
undergraduate years how many of you had
a course that really got you into this
skill set to people it's just not part
of our culture it was only defined in
1998 right I want to share with you some
of the research we've measured just tens
of thousands of children and adults
emotional intelligence and here's what
we know that students with greater
emotional intelligence have less anxiety
they have less depression they're less
likely to abuse drugs alcohol and
cigarettes less likely to be aggressive
and bully others so here we are showing
that these emotions skills are making a
difference in multiple aspects of
children's lives and it goes on they
have greater leadership skills they are
more attentive and less hyperactive in
school and they also perform better
we notice also about teachers teachers
with greater emotional intelligence are
just generally more positive about
teaching in their schools they receive
more support from their principals the
report greater job satisfaction and less
burnout one thing that we've done a lot
of in the last few years is moved beyond
the study of the emotional intelligence
of the individual and starts studying
what does it look like to have an
emotionally intelligent classroom how do
you go into a classroom and videotape
for example the interactions between
teachers and students and among students
themselves and look for the behaviors
associated with emotional intelligence
like positive nonverbal behavior while
teaching like a teacher who regards
students perspectives sensitive to
students needs not so cynical and when
we code the interactions between
teachers and students what we find is
that you can rate an emotional climate
you can also do other things like the
instructional skills and the classroom
organizational components however what
we find is that the emotional climate is
the most predictive it's the most
predictive of things like students be
engaged in learning it's the most
predictive of students having better
quality relationships with their
teachers and less aggressive behavior
more pro-social behavior and importantly
higher academic performance in these
studies we're not just coding for these
climates we're also looking at classroom
size teacher education level school size
socioeconomic status all these things
are controlled in these studies and over
and over again what we're finding is
that emotional climate makes the
difference when you go to the workforce
guess what managers and leaders with
higher emotional intelligence just do
better from having greater sensitivity
and empathy to be more effective to
getting more merit increases higher
performance ratings teams have faster
cohesion support each other better
communicate more effectively perform
better and CEOs even say too about their
employees with greater emotional
intelligence these
people that I want to be around these
are the people I want to be with me
everybody asks you know how does
emotional intelligence develop and of
course it develops through a variety of
mechanisms some of us are just more
naturally emotionally intelligent we're
just our area of our brains that are
associate with reading people it just
has more neurons so you're looking
around constant you're getting
information from the world around us
there's also the temperament piece isn't
there how many of you are just more
prone to be worried and anxious anyone
yeah this is okay I am that person so I
worry a lot I was where I was I took
patient thing with a senator god I feel
so short you know I can never be a
politician it's like Oh worried about
that and then people from the Department
of Education like oh my goodness like
I'm just a psychologist and then I'm
thinking last night what am I going to
say to these people is going to work is
I'm not going to work and I say good I
got to talk to myself you've done a
million presentation going to be fine
and then I start worrying about why I'm
worrying and it's just sort of like this
genetic thing look hey I have skills
luckily I can check in say hey how you
feeling all right really how you feeling
and of course we have nurture don't we
we have the people that raised us and
probably their emotional intelligence
influence our emotional intelligence so
you know I always say I grew up with a
very neurotic mother you know go figure
my anxiety and my mother would say
something like this when I was a
teenager
welcome having a breakdown right and I
remember thinking like I'm 12 mom like
I'm not sure I'm the person that's going
to help you but well you know maybe we
can talk about it you know and my father
was this kind of you know angry man I
mean he was a good father my parents
were good but my father had some anger
issues you know and it was without
arguing all the time you know and so
this is what you learn you know you
learn for example while my mother was a
loving mother you know I learned that
she was a little bit of an avoider so
when I was bullied as a kid it would be
things like don't worry it's going to go
away yeah your parents loved you and I
was like but I need skills you know I
didn't say that back then I say that now
like love is wonderful I feel so
supported here but when I'm in this
environment love is not helping me I
need some real skills to help me get
through this day and to figure out how
to manage my life so what I hope happens
is that we give everybody these skills
from preschool to high school and beyond
so that we can ensure that everyone gets
a developmentally appropriate emotional
intelligence education so why are we
here because I hope that we agree that
there are not enough concrete tools
available to schools and to families to
teach these skills so what I want to
wrap up my presentation with is the
sharing with you some of the tools that
we've developed and and their impact
ruler is a program that was developed in
our Center it has been in existence for
many many years I was very fortunate in
my career and one of the reasons why I
survived being a teenager who was
bullied was because I had an uncle who
was a magnificent educator and so I owe
my career to my uncle who was a middle
school teacher who essentially was the
one that gave me the words who gave me
the strategies because he knew better
somehow or another and when I was in my
early twenties I decided to work with my
uncle on a project to develop emotional
intelligence among middle schoolers and
we work together the blind leading the
blind in terms of writing a program
because he was a retired teacher I was
just going to get my graduate work done
and we just struggle trying to put
together a program and we got a few
people to use it and it just it didn't
work and we realized that we were we had
challenges because we were asking
teachers back 20 years ago to teach
concepts like alienation anxiety and
what we found was there was a lot of
resistance there was unlocked
comfortable talking about alienation
anxiety so we had to go back to the
drawing board and develop the adults we
had to teach teachers to be more
emotionally skilled themselves but then
we went into schools and superintendent
and principals we've extracted you know
their BlackBerry's running around saying
you know oh we're going to do this
training for our faculty they're going
they really need it like well the way
you just did it with your hand I think
you really need it just like so we had
to really work with the leaders of
schools so they walk the talk and that's
why it says it involves all stakeholders
because from our perspective everyone at
a school who works in a school from an
administrative assistant who is reading
people in the morning to transportation
staff who are seeing kids on the bus a
lot of bullying happens on the bus what
if the bus driver were to check kids off
on the mood meter as the kids were
getting on the bus and we're to read
those expressions it wow what's going on
how different would that be focusing
positive development we believe it's an
umbrella for all the work that's being
done in character education and bullying
etc has to align with common core
standards as you now know we also want
to make sure we're promoting teacher
effectiveness and creating a positive
school climate and importantly it can't
be something that's done at Thursday on
Thursday the two o'clock let's talk
about feelings okay good open up what is
ever going to my mouth now that's not
your feelings everywhere aren't they
think about the day in the life of a
student from 7:00 a.m. to 3:00 or 4:00
in the afternoon in and out of
classrooms lunch room recess physical
education we feed back on their on their
grades endless endless experiences so
what are these anchors the first is
called the emotional intelligence
charter we believe that it's important
to move away from having classroom rules
and school rules
to really getting kids to think about
the environment that they want to live
in asking kids themselves how do you
want to feel when you come to school how
do you want to feel in that classroom
when you're in gym when you're in the
lunchroom and these kids come up with
the most amazing words like I want to
feel comfortable I want to feel
respected I want to feel safe I was just
in Seattle in a third-grade classroom
and one kid this classroom charted eight
these kids had we want to feel selfless
imagine that third graders using the
word selfless and I of course I'm a
skeptic I'm a scientist like you got to
be kidding me
you know I went to the teacher said you
gave them that word right she said
honestly they came up with on their own
I'm like they came up with a word
selfless and I interviewed the kids and
this one kid said um you know
everybody's so narcissistic I'm like
what whatever but when you give children
the opportunity they can tell you more
things than you ever imagined they can
tell you the behaviors that they want to
engage it and they can show you ways
that they would prevent and manage
conflict effectively then we teach
self-awareness through our mood meter
building that vocabulary learning how do
you get from the red to the green how do
you go from the green to the yellow what
are the strategies our third tool is
called the meta moment
this is our tool for building
self-regulation how many of you have
triggers like emotional triggers anyone
like like triggers that would like
literally like they they like activate
your brain in a way that you turn red
and you you know you feel like your
heads going to blow up
anybody have those yeah how many have
like a hundred
we all have triggers often times kids
who bully others are triggered through
things that don't trigger other kids so
easily
maybe they miss reading a facial
expression we now know that bully kids
who bully others tend to have a hostile
attribution bias and see in mutual face
it hey what are you looking at like this
guy here like are you interested oh
you're being dismissive
I'm sure I am I'm having a hard time
here you got a problem and that's what
happens a lot in that bullying cycle so
what happens also how many ever notice
that when you are hijacked I mean when
you have that amygdala pumping that all
of a sudden you remember everything in
your life that you don't like and
everyone who you don't like and you
think about even a relationship you're
in you go back 20 years and you said you
remember one on vacation 20 years ago
and your last week you promised it is do
you remember this and remember this and
if you're in a classroom as a teacher
and this happens with a student and I
know I should have left before I got
tenure and I knew like what am I doing
here now I'm stuck this is ridiculous
one is summer vacation and you go in
through that cycle we want to stop that
cycle so we have a six step process
something happens you sense it you pay
attention and you think and you
recognize very clearly what's happening
in your brain the thoughts that are
going off the deep end and you stop and
you breathe and you say wait a minute I
need to bring it down but breathing is
not enough because there's any way we're
taking that breath and you go ah I'm
going to kill you
so what we want to do is shift our
mindset and what we've learned is that
if you teach people to activate an image
of their best possible self things
shaped things shift for the better I'd
like you to take a moment and think
about your best self right now everyone
please sit up straight in your seats
good posture you'll live longer
take a nice long inhale and exhale close
your eyes for a moment if you're
comfortable and if you were asked as you
were leaving here today for the word the
adjective that describes you when you
were your best what would that word be
if you're an educator and you're in the
classroom what is the one word that
describes you when you're being the best
educator if you're a parent what word
describes you when you're being the best
parent you have one word think another
one
please open your eyes and the question I
have for you is that when you're
triggered if you practice more and more
activating that image of your best self
do you believe that you might choose
more effective strategies how many of
you think that might be a possibility
well we know it is that when I say mark
and you know I was very fortunate
students in my class about seven or so
years ago or an article about this
course that I taught on emotional
intelligence and they they gave me the
name the feelings master right I was
like wow feelings master yeah probably
about my jacket and I remember thinking
like what a how does a feelings master
interact in the world right better
posture right and I get a lot of
students sometimes they're entitled and
I say things like you know professor
Brackett I've got a question but I'm not
sure you're gonna know the answer and
it's like really kidding me like if you
read that research I've done on like
teachers emotions and grading and the
what I'm about to read your paper honey
anyway the I've noticed even in my own
life that when I'm able to say mark who
would bring that feelings master out
when I'm triggered somehow or another
the feelings master doesn't want to say
something hurtful somehow another
feelings measures and continue thinking
negative thoughts because I've taken the
energy away from the object and I
brought it back to myself and say
something like wow you're you want to be
an empathic person an empathic person
doesn't engage in this kind of behavior
what are those strategies like positive
self-talk positive reappraisal of course
we can't always get through the moment
sometimes we even take that meta moment
but we need to problem-solve we need to
find the root of the problem so our
problem-solving tool we call the
blueprint which gets kids away from
thinking only about themselves and now
thinking about the other what happened
to the other person what was that person
feeling oh I have no idea oh really
maybe if you knew what other the person
was feeling it
more information maybe it was the other
person strategy that influenced you
so the blueprint not only hasn't
described what happened but gives them
the time to reflect and think critically
about their own emotions the reasons for
those emotions their own strategies but
also those of others and we've seen just
great things happen for example in
schools when they take this seriously
kids will complete this blueprint
independently then they'll switch I
thought you were making this facial
expression at me no I was looking at the
clock cuz I was bored
oh really I thought you were dissing me
no I wasn't well the whole thing was a
misunderstanding and importantly it's
for everyone so these are some artifacts
this actually we have guests here from
hand in Connecticut and these are
charters from him the first one is from
hand in the middle one when we studied
every teacher in Hamden a few years ago
asking them how do they want to feel
this is what they told us they wanted to
feel more respect they wanted feel
support they wanted to feel safe
motivated successful and happy and then
the teachers themselves think about well
what can I do to create a community that
feels more respectful that will be I do
support others this is one in Spanish in
a preschool where the kids can't write
yet so what they did is a user
thumbprint to sign their charter as you
can see there are a million uses of the
millimeter just a million uses of it
from teaching facial expressions to
building the vocabulary to developing
emotion regulation strategies - an app
that will be released in a few months
where you can plot yourself and get
reports at the end of every week to show
you where you've lived on the mood meter
- using the mood meter in special
education classroom with children who
can't speak and they can drag their
photo into the quadrant and the computer
will give them words so they can
actually share their feelings with
people that they wouldn't been able to
do otherwise
we have more advanced work that we do as
well we call it the feeling words
curriculum where we teach educators how
to intentionally integrate emotions into
the curriculum through a process that we
use that has five steps the one is
sharing stories about your own
experiences being alienated you know I
have my family member
my brother says to me Martina you
shouldn't be telling everybody that
you're a bully they'll think you're weak
what you know the only reason why I'm
successful I'm so self disclosing you
know it's like what I have to show yeah
I feel pretty good about it I think it's
important I think children who that I
speak with when they look at me they say
you're a professor you're a Europe you
know you're a doctor and and you were
bullied you know there's hope for kids
they have to know that we've all
experienced this and why are we so
afraid to be open and authentic so we
want teachers to create those
experiences for kids early on so there's
no weirdness about emotion in the
classroom but it's got to be linked to
the curriculum so when you're doing the
Holocaust why not focus on alienation
it's got to be brought to the home so
the parents can be learning these words
and they can also be sharing their own
stories I'll never forget this one that
what alienation just reminded me of a
school online I was in recently where
they had done that word or during that
two-week period and there was that they
posted their family response and it's
one parent was a police officer a woman
and she wrote a beautiful story with her
daughter about how she's felt alienated
in her career because she's the only
woman on the police force and how the
guys do this and how she always felt
isolated and and left out that daughter
would never known that about her mother
had it not been for a lesson on
alienation the creative connection
getting kids to do drawings and other
activities to activate sort of the other
areas of the brain where we know that
children need to develop divergent
thinking ability it's interesting isn't
it when you have to solve a math problem
it's sort of like there's a correct
answer right but when you were
challenged emotionally how many of you
ever had like a really like difficult
experience and how many we found like oh
there's just one right answer uh-uh it's
complex you got to weigh these things
out you got to think of my god if I do
this what's going to be the
repercussions
how's this going to impact me how are we
teaching kids to think that way
these are the real-world problem-solving
skills and of course we want to give
them the skills
to be more able to manage their emotions
so we get kids to work in groups to
think about a variety of strategies
remember children are different
so as the introvert I don't want to talk
to a lot of people when I'm feeling sad
right I want to be alone I want to think
about it some more the extrovert might
need to socialize so we want to give
children lots of options because there
is not one way to be healthy in terms of
managing emotions once it talked very
briefly before I end about the alignment
of our work with the Common Core
Standards and I won't go into a lot of
detail about this but you can see here
that just one tool the mood meter
across all grade levels through the
lessons and activities that we teach is
giving kids those skills of speaking and
listening and building language speaking
listening and reading here's just one
example this is a lesson using the mood
meter in the Holocaust where they're
reading a book in fifth grade called the
boy in the Striped Pyjamas and they are
doing an analysis of the emotions of the
characters in the book they're taking
Shmuel and they're looking at schmoes
experiences how did he feel when this
happened how do you feel when that
happened what caused him to have those
feelings where's the evidence in the
text that demonstrate that what was the
strategy that Shmuel use that led to
this so they're simultaneously
developing emotional intelligence
critical thinking we're very concerned
in Connecticut about teacher
effectiveness domain to is one of the
domains that we feel we can help
teachers receive exemplary scores on why
is that well when you have a classroom
charter you're creating a positive
learning environment that is responsive
and respectful to the learning needs of
students you're promoting student
engagement and shared responsibility for
learning so over and over again we're
not thinking about adding something in
we're actually helping you achieve the
goals that you want to have to create a
positive learning environment where
students can learn another example with
the mood meter the movement is not just
for teaching emotion vocabulary it's
actually a tool for differentiating
instruction don't you want kids to be
yellow and they're brainstorming when
they're having generating ideas don't
you want them to be in the green
when they're doing journaling and
reflection activities don't you want to
teach them how to be persuasive and
getting that read so they can be
competitive and they can be a good
debater and sometimes you need to be in
the blue when you're doing some proofing
or editing so right then in there we're
helping teachers create learning
environments where students are more
engaged and they're differentiating
instruction and giving kids what we call
a mood congruent learning experience
children will remember more and learn
better when the content matches the mood
same thing with the meta moment the
blueprint we're promoting appropriate
behavioral standards giving kids the
research-based strategies to help them
manage emotions and to problem-solve
we have an approach we call ruler there
are other approaches to social and
emotional learning and my hope is that
whatever approach you decide to adopt
and I'm really encourage you to take
obviously social emotional learning
seriously that make sure it has these
components training for leaders teachers
and staff so that everyone is involved
in the education of emotional
intelligence that there's a classroom
level work that you're also involving
the families one thing that we spend
considerable time on is making sure that
the same tools children learn in the
classroom parents are learning to use at
home think about it wouldn't it be
wonderful if in the morning a mother or
father said good morning honey where you
on the mood meter you're in the red this
morning why what's going on well mommy
I'm feeling anxious about the test today
my goodness you're anxious Wow let's
think about some strategies that we go
to school together to help you decrease
that anxiety how many of you would like
that to happen for your students I think
it would be wonderful wouldn't it what
we know is that when you involve
everyone you're enhancing
social-emotional skills of individuals
but also shifting the culture and
climate a shared language and finally
what we now know is that great things
happen in terms of outcomes so that's
we're going to wrap up with we know that
schools that have adopted ruler have
students with greater emotional
intelligence less anxiety and depression
fewer attention learning problems higher
academic performance that are problem
solvers
in terms of that climate we've shown up
to a 17% shift in classroom climate what
we show is that the emotional climate is
the initial driver of that change and by
the second year the instructional skills
of teachers become even better
so in conclusion I'm going to ask you
like I asked you in the beginning how
are you feeling everyone please sit up
straight in your seats take a nice long
inhale exhale how many feel a little
different than you did when you came
this morning raise your hand okay how
many of you feeling slightly more
pleasant I'm not going to ask the other
one like it it close your eyes for a
minute and imagine that you're going to
leave here today and text message
someone and you're going to tell them
the one thing that's a take-home message
for you about emotional intelligence and
social-emotional learning what are you
gonna say what's the one thing that
resonates with you from this
presentation your one take-home message
ok please open your eyes in conclusion
as an academic and our team here as a
team of academics and people who are
involved in the practice of emotional
intelligence we can't make audacious
claims about our work we can only say
what our research shows and what the
anecdotes come in from what the
antidotes say as they come in from our
thousands of schools now hundreds of
schools around the globe but James
Heckman I think said it best Nobel
laureate in economics he said the
greatest returns and education
investments are from nurturing
children's non cognitive skills
I don't love the term non cognitive
skills because I do think of emotional
intelligence being a very cognitive
skill it's a very hard skill but we need
to give children the social emotional
and behavior benefits that lead to later
success in life so my final words are I
hope that we're in agreement that the
time has come at least in Connecticut to
take the social and emotional education
of his children seriously thank you very
much
you